if you
zoom in you can see that in the corner
there on her right hand side it's a dark
square
so that's when the bone is turned the
wrong way
hi i'm susan polgar i have won four
world champs championships
as well as five olympic gold medals and
i have broken the gender barrier in
chess
today we are gonna look at some video
segments from movies where chess has
been an important part
actually this game that they are playing
is based on a real game
that was played by two grand masters who
happen to be both friends of mine
the ukrainian vasily evancho and
the american patrick wolf they play this
game
up to this point that in 1993
the fiction started in the movie from a
certain position
in a few moves that went into different
direction the actual game and they
didn't draw between two
those two grandmasters in i think 72
moves
the game is having a break it's called
adjourned
even in those days it actually gave an
unfair advantage to the side who had
better
coaches or friends or helpers to do the
analysis of that
adjourned position that option is no
longer existing today
in real life opponents don't usually
stare at each other this much or look at
each other to some
degree they look a little bit but they
are just usually more busy in
trying to figure out the best moves and
calculations
just players some look at the ceiling
some don't but
regardless that's pretty much what is
happening when we calculate our
variation
we see the pieces moving even though we
have a certain specific position right
in front of us
we need to foresee when the pieces move
one two three five tenths when he moves
ahead sometimes in reality
some grandmasters do that that they look
away from the actual board
look at the ceiling or somewhere just
almost in a way that the position that
is physically actually in front of them
on the chess board
she sacrificed the queen which is very
unusual because it's the most valuable
piece we have
in chess so she got
her queen back because when a cone
reaches all the way across it can
promote to any piece including the queen
so now she has a major material
advantage at this point in the game
the only thing she needs to worry about
that if
borgo starts giving checks and she
blocked the track
the chuck makes an attack on the king
and now the black queen again is
attacking
the white king and now she finally found
a square for her king
when there are no more dangerous sharks
and therefore right material advantages
overwhelming
and i think we'll see the end of the
game right here
[Music]
you know i was a pioneer in a man's
world of chess and
i didn't have such nice treatments i was
invited
to a major elite tournament in spain
back in 1987 and one of the top players
in the world at the time who was one of
the participants he objected that
what are women doing in such a
prestigious elite tournament women
shouldn't be invited
and another six-time u.s champion
that i played actually earlier
swiped the pieces of the board so this
is uh
kind of a little bit of idealistic world
and
not the reality not in the 70s or 80s
or 90s when i was actively playing and i
think even less so in the 50s or 60s
[Music]
so they're playing reasonable starting
moves and
normal opening moves so a good club
player could do it as well
three games is a lot and playing with a
clock i think they are playing five
minutes which is a traditional blitz
game
five minutes for the entire game playing
without the clock
uh i have played actually 326
games simultaneously which was a world
record at the time so
three is not so much compared to that
you're not seeing half of the chessboard
and actual moves to tell whether they
are or not
when it comes to the moves they are all
definitely possible positions and
there's nothing illegal
[Music]
she was tipping over her opponent's
kings
in i think a few occasions that's not
something that
anybody would do traditionally
historically tipping over the king
used to be the sign of resigning the
game i definitely give thumbs up i
really like the series because it really
gave a huge boost for chess in general
in the mainstream
i actually really like this scene it was
one of my favorites i think
the position was very visible you could
see
all the pieces
i remember when i was in moscow and i've
seen a tournament
when i was still like 11 and 12 years
old
they were moving those big pieces on
those big demonstration boards
and now we can view games live through
the internet but back in the days it was
like this that they had those so-called
demonstration boards
to relay the actual moves to larger
crowds
there is a very special thing ongoing on
the board
with this very last move that we see
right now with the knight capturing
the bishop
it is a winning position because now the
black king is under attack it's in check
and in the upcoming moves that would
follow up
would lead to either major material gain
for white or checkmate
so one of the things that a lot of
beginner players or
nancy's players don't understand that
why
people could resign until the checkmate
comes right and
at the same time it's between
experienced players it's very normal
that they don't play the game all the
way out
when they see that checkmate is coming
in two
three four five moves or even more than
that or they lose their queen
which is one of them most important
pieces you know
they they would give the respect to the
opponent
that okay i know what's coming i
congratulations sir
a brilliant clothing is not so much part
of the chat
scene it could be because the game
itself was so aesthetically pleasing
it's just something unusual you did
something funny or tricky or you know
and that's what happened a little bit
here so they were enjoying it
as an art as a performance chest-wise it
was also one of the best
i would definitely would give a tan you
there d5
so those were very normal starting moves
it's called the center counter or
scandinavian defense
but then i think they were more focused
on the visuals of uh
pieces getting captured and eliminated
the first
three moves actually that they did play
on the board
are very clear and very realistic they
don't show even the whole board and it's
very hard to make out what's going on
after that
toby is a great actor and everything but
just the pure fact that
he's just so much smaller in size than
his opponent here spasky the real bobby
fischer
who has been a friend of mine and i knew
well he's a
very tall big guy and humongous hands
fisher has abandoned his trademark
sicilian opening
talk about the finisher abandoning his
favorite sicilian opening
the sicilian is not white's choice
i mean bobby fisher used to be known to
start
almost all his games with his king
pawn to e4 and moving the pawn up two
squares in front of his king
that allows the sicilian but sistilian
is a choice of
black not of white so that's a little
bit inaccurate i would say when it comes
to
uh phrasing it that way that he
abandoned the sicilian he abandoned
allowing the sicilian but he didn't
abandon the sicilian
bobby used to be known to play an e4
player which means starting the game
with moving the phone up in front of his
king and in this game that's being shown
in this segment
as well as in the real game six of the
match uh fischer
started with c4 moving the pawn in front
of his
queenside bishop and that's the first
time you've ever done that
and that's actually is really important
because the element of surprise
is quite important in chess and that's
what he was shooting for
in this game and actually i learned from
it and when i played my
world championship against the chinese
champion xijjun
i also did that similar trick in that i
was known
to usually start with d4 with the phone
in front of my queen
and that helped within my last fourth
world championship i also started
with a different move moving my phone in
front of my king
so this is very unusual that somebody
would smile
and be so nice but i know boris posky
he's been a friend of mine for many many
years and
actually that's what he did at the
actual championship but it's very
very uncommon usually people are closer
to crying and holding their tears back
then smiling
this is the final round of our rabushani
national chess championship
fiona mutesi and christine namaganda are
tied for first position in the women's
category
they will now play the final deciding
game everything is correct
we can see the first few moves that
queen's gun bit coincidentally
where black has a choice to accept the
gambit that would mean to capture the
pawn on
c4 or play the declined
you see the focus and the concentration
of the players here
fiona who is actually a real person
you belong here you're not supposed to
just speak loudly and disturb the
concentration of the players
well once in a while it happens but it's
very very rare
and usually that person is being
escorted out
immediately when that may happen i mean
there has been some extreme situation
when somebody got really sick or even
died during the just tournament
but uh other than that it's just not
normal that people speak
i managed to figure out the exact
positions and then what was going on
so i would definitely give a very high
mark for the
technical expertise of the directors and
chess advisors here because they did a
good job in
very realistically showing
the actual chess positions
[Music]
as you can see the opponent got all the
way to the other end
and you can see that whole sequence that
they make a move they press the clock
they ride the move down
so that's also very correct i would give
this
segment definitely a 10. does that
foolish law
or one just like it and come for you
not as practical to see through the
board to differentiate even the colors
which one is the white which one is the
black
but it's obviously visually very
pleasing and your children
it does i mean here they indeed
trash talk or psych each other out which
obviously is the normal in in casual
games or
coffee house chests or in parks but not
be a part of competition chess
we may play somebody we don't like as
much or they don't like us
it's kind of life and yeah sometimes
they have
they try to psych you out and
you know get into your head like stare
at you or
bang a piece make a movie the very loud
movement
or something like that or
you know that it's called bad
sportsmanship
what do you do when you wake up to that
so psychology can be very important and
it starts out right from the very
beginning
because in the beginning of the game
there are many
starting options and people have their
favorite
options to start the game and
it's a little psychological war on going
right from the first move whether whose
preparation
will be actually on the board who will
walk into the other side's let's say
they both prepared for the same thing
who got deeper into it so that's a real
interesting psychological game right
from the beginning
and let's say they got out of that and
nobody got a
significant advantage then later in the
game
it's about how do you feel about your
position in any of these movies and
segments
is that they intentionally or not don't
show
enough of the chest moves unlike in this
gambit
you can clearly say something is wrong
if you zoom in you can see that
in the corner there on her right hand
side it's a dark square
so that's when the bond is turned the
wrong way which is a very typical
mistake by the way there are so many
commercials and
some movie scenes when they don't pay
attention to the details but also the
pieces are kind of
pretty random on the board as well so so
this is the one that
this thumbs down when it comes to the
just technical part
you